à sinabang
la bande annonce de l'adaptation
télévisuelle de l'ami prodigieuse a
beaucoup fait réagir ses lectrices
agitent leurs idiots mon dieu oui
vraiment je m'appelle de passage
candidats étaient littéralement
bouleversé par les livres de l'auteur et
les nymphes rnt qui parlent d'amitié
dans les années cinquante à naples et
relations sont durs sont fort puisque
j'ai trouvé ça vraiment c'était criant
de vérité pour moi l'ami prodigieuse est
un véritable phénomène
les quatre tomes ont été traduits en 40
langues et 10 millions d'exemplaires se
sont vendus donc 100 milles au québec
c'est un phénomène vraiment
comme on a rarement vu dans la
littérature d'ici et d'ailleurs il ya
quelque chose de très très très social
et en même temps de très vrai et cette
écriture le tout en finesse et en
douceur pour ajouter au phénomène on ne
connaît pas la véritable identité de
l'auteur elena frente est un pseudonyme
un journaliste dans le capital y en a
même tenter de démasquer l'écrivaine
provoquant l'ire de ses fins
ces phases les plus sincères ceux qui
adorent et une apparente et se contente
de l'oeuvre d'une force d'une réalité de
9 d'une lucidité c'est ce qui fait la
richesse de cette plume et de cette
femme là
bon je travaille les bravos roshi doute
tolère le très modéré l'ami prodigieuse
est maintenant adapté à la télévision en
italien avec sous titres en anglais pour
la chaîne et du bio canal+ diffusera
avec le sous titre en français à compter
du 10 décembre est pour rien au monde
quand tu ne manqueras l'émission je
parle pas encore je suis le voir en même
temps que tout le monde ici judith
jasmin boudreau qui radio-canada à
montréal avec ce bouquin qui perd là
mais la vie a gagné vingt mille fiable